nous allons parler du reste de
l'actualité dans notre région avec
d'abord cette disparition inquiétante de
doute de toute une famille à nantes
les parents agnès et xavier âgé d'une
cinquantaine d'années et leurs quatre
enfants de 14 17 19 et 20 ans ne donne
plus de nouvelles depuis une semaine
maintenant des volets de leur maison
située au boulevard schuman à nantes
sont clos ce départ qui s'est fait sans
prévenir personne ni la famille ni les
écoles des enfants semblent malgré tout
organisée et préméditée par la famille
les enquêteurs ne saurions pas de façon
privilégiée vers une piste criminelle
car aucune trace de violence
aucune trace suspecte n'a été détectée
dans la maison du couple un couple et
ses quatre enfants ont donc disparu à
nantes depuis le début du mois et
l'enquêté s'oriente aujourd'hui vers un
geste criminel
les enquêteurs ont retrouvé trois corps
sous la terrasse dans le jardin à
camille pont vieux derrière cette vache
dissimulant la maison familiale
les fouilles ont duré toute la journée
trois corps ont finalement été retrouvés
sous la terrasse
il s'agirait de la mère et des deux fils
aînés selon le procureur il aurait été
abattu par arme à feu
les parents et leurs quatre enfants
avait disparu depuis trois semaines la
découverte des corps donne un nouveau
tournant à l'anc est ok tu bascules donc
malheureusement nettement sur une
qualification criminelle de
séquestration
la famille vivait à nantes depuis
plusieurs années les parents et leurs
quatre enfants trois garçons et une
fille âgés de 13 à 21 ans tous bien
intégré selon le voisinage des gens
normaux
famille normale a quatre enfants
bien implanté dans le quartier bien
implantée dans l'épaule voilà sans
histoire on a trouvé mon bizarre que
c'était fermé mais je sont partis en
vacances je sais tout ça peut arriver
espérons cependant c'est
les choses il y a trois semaines le père
xavier de ligonnès semble organisé le
départ de la famille
la maison est vide et de courriers sont
adressés aux collèges et lycées des
enfants pour expliquer le départ de la
famille c'est de l'appeler début avril
sur portable est éteint
on n'a plus de nouvelles jusqu'à l'été
dans notre classe deux semaines et après
en fait ce soir les recherches se
poursuivent
deux autres corps sont recherchés dans
la fosse où les premiers ont été
retrouvés nathalie perez vous êtes à
nantes près de la maison du couple quels
sont les derniers éléments de l'enquète
bien déjà pour ce qui ce pour ce qui est
de l'anc est pour l'instant les
enquêteurs donc sont au travail mais
nous nous ce que nous savons de cette
famille c'est qu'elle vivait ici dans
cette rue calme d'un quartier bourgeois
de la ville de nantes la famille donc
une famille nombreuse plutôt aisée
catholique pratiquante en effet la mère
enseignait le catéchisme et participer à
de nombreuses activités caritatives au
sein de sa paroisse quant au père lui il
était employé comme directeur commercial
dans une agence publicitaire
quant aux enfants les deux plus jeunes
suivent est une parfaite scolarité dans
un établissement privé très réputé et
les deux aînés étaient étudiants ici
tout le quartier sous le choc les
voisins qui les connaissaient très bien
que nous avons rencontrés nous parle
d'une famille très appréciée d'une
famille unie sans histoire en apparence
bref des gens qu'on fait ici qu'on ne
connaissait très bien qu'on aimait
beaucoup
personne n'arrive à comprendre ce qu'il
a pu se passer quel drame a pu se nouer
derrière ces murs épilogue macabre donc
pour ce qui était jusque là une
disparition mystérieuse
trois corps et même un quatrième juste à
l'instant été découvert au domicile d'un
couple et de ses quatre enfants des gens
qualifiés de sans histoire mais qui
n'avait pas donné signe de vie depuis le
4 avril dernier à nantes romale bonnan
gabriel camilla c'est dans le jardin de
cette maison nantaise dissimulé
désormais derrière une haie
en bâche noire que les enquêteurs ont
trouvé les corps de trois personnes
tuées vraisemblablement par arme à feu
ce 2 3 des membres de la famille de
ligonnès tous enveloppés dans des draps
et enterrées dans la propriété depuis
début avril
xavier lepercq agnès la mère ainsi que
les quatre enfants âgés de 14 à 21 ans
n'avait plus donné signe de vie
dans un premier temps la justice avait
lancé un avis de disparition inquiétante
aujourd'hui la sphère prend un nouveau
coup aux quêtes bascule donc
malheureusement nettement sur une
qualification criminelle de
séquestration et d'assassinât selon les
premiers éléments de l'enquète un départ
précipité de la famille avait été
programmé une lettre avait été envoyée
aux écoles pour des scolarisés les
enfants avec un motif une mutation en
australie depuis les téléphones
portables était resté muet plus aucun
mouvement sur les cartes bancaires seuls
quelques proches voisins avaient
remarqué les allées et venues troublante
du père ce qui m'intrigue et c'était son
le ballet l'acquitterez n'arrêtait pas
de traverser et de remplir le coffre de
sacs de gros cabas
voilà donc et en bermuda pour lucho sur
bateau effectivement c'est ça s'est
décidé à mon compagnon gym qu'est-ce qui
fait le voisin pour ceux qui
fréquentaient la famille le drame
demeure inexplicable la cheville était
très gentil les parents étaient gentils
sarianne avec avec tout le monde et
c'est pour ça que je comprends pas ça un
peu à l'instar pour moi désormais la
police recherche ce véhicule 4 4
appartenant à la famille et un appel à
témoins a été lancé
les enquêteurs en ont désormais la
conviction l'assassinât à nantes d'une
mère et de ses quatre enfants âgés de 13
à 20 ans a été prémédité organisé dans
le moindre détail
un homme est actuellement recherché le
père deux jours après la découverte des
corps tout semble l'accabler voyez le
reportage de nathalie perez et anne-lise
bertieaux dans le centre de tir de la
banlieue de nantes où s'est entraîné
très sérieusement
xavier dupont de ligonnès voici l'homme
qui a appris à xavier dupont de ligonnès
à se servir d'une arme et a tiré avec
précision la structure fait sa
connaissance en février dernier très
vite des relations amicales s'installe
entre les deux hommes quelques jours
avant le drame le père de famille
lui demande des conseils pour utiliser
une vie et carabine il m'a parlé d'une
arme qu'il avait hérité de son père et
il a apporté cette arme je l'examiné
j'ai nettoyé parce que visiblement avais
pas tiré depuis 20 ans chez nettoyer
parce que c'est quand on a un outil de
précision qui se respecte il me parle de
cette arme me parle de éventuellement
l'utilité d'un silencieux et comme un
centre de tir c'est prévu pour faire du
bruit
l'âge d'un silencieux aucun intérêt quoi
dans tous les stands de tir tout comme
celui qu'il fréquentait depuis le début
de l'année les tests d'inscription ne
porte pas sur l'état mental de
l'adhérent si on leur apprend d'abord un
manier une arme mais surtout on leur
apprend la sécurité parce qu'une arme
elle est dangereuse que par une sa
manipulation
xavier dupont de ligonnès venez
accompagné de deux de ses fils les
adolescents avaient suivi une initiation
au tir avec le même instructeur que leur
père ça choque un peu déjà d'avoir
effectivement
on a dû arrêter un des acteurs d'une
arme qui a servi à qui visait à faire un
quintuple meurtre en fin de journée les
enquêteurs ont quitté la scène de crime
avec toujours cette question que s'est
il passé d'ailleurs ces murs où ce soir
encore des anonymes venaient
discrètement déposé quelques fleurs
c'est ce lycée privé d'une petite ville
de vendée que fréquentait arthur l'aîné
de la fratrie avait souhaité s'éloigner
de sa famille durant la semaine le jeune
homme de 20 ans louait une chambre chez
l'habitant ses logeurs en garde un
souvenir ému
il était super sympa lité rigolo même
est très gentil il puis bombe avec qui
on pourrait parler quoi le problème est
très poli ça j'adore
élément troublant selon ses logeurs
arthur aurait laissé ses affaires
soigneusement empaquetée avant de
disparaître
oui oui dans les châteaux weiss fait
est-ce que c'est lui qui me tue ses
affaires dans des sacs bien plié du tout
qu'on se bat même incompréhension dans
le petit village de l'yonne où agnès
dupont de ligonnès et ses quatre enfants
passaient leurs vacances
les habitants ont appris le drame avec
effroi ici tout le monde connaissait la
famille
il faut quand même pas oublier que c'est
une très vieille famille de noah hier
c'est une très vieille famille de myriam
moi je suis d'image connais j'ai vécu
j'étais petit ici j'ai toujours connu
cette fan cette famille
surpris parce que bon je n'ai pas le
genre de famille en lequel on s'attend à
des évènements de ce temps le père de
famille xavier dupont de ligonnès
principal suspect dans cette affaire est
lui toujours introuvable personnalité
floue avec de nombreuses zones d'ombré
selon les enquêteurs il est aujourd'hui
l'homme le plus recherché de france
je vous le disais les enquêteurs ont
donc mis la main sur les ultimes message
du père des enfants qui est aussi le
principal suspect juste avant sa fuite
c'était sur internet quelques jours
après les meurtres
audrey richier c'est une nouvelle
facette de xavier dupont de ligonnès un
catholique fervent proche de l'obsession
depuis 2009 il postait des messages
plusieurs fois par jour sur ce forum
catholique sur internet
le 8 avril 2011 soit quelques jours
après la mort de sa femme et de ses
enfants
il intervenait encore sous le pseudo
ligot ce jour là rien sur sa famille
mais une discussion sur les ancêtres de
jésus en mai 2010 en revanche il parlait
de son mariage comme d'un sacrifice pour
dieu choisir sa femme en fonction de
convictions religieuses identique en
préférant une ex à une nouvelle rémy
protestante impossible à convertir comme
son mari agnès dupont de ligonnès
s'exprimait sur internet mais il n'était
pas au courant
ces pseudonymes agnès skorpios changer
souvent et ses propos ne concernaient
pas la religion mais sa souffrance au
quotidien
en 2004 elle parle d'un mariage sans
qu'elle décrit avec ces mots trop
cassant trop sec trop rigide trop
militaire selon sa femme
xavier dupont de ligonnès n'hésitez pas
à évoquer la mort de toute la famille
lui demander s'il est heureux que ce
soit maintenant ou il ya dix ans la
réponse est sans doute la même oui oui
mais si on pouvait tous mourir demain
quel pied la mère de famille c'est
penche aussi sur les soucis financiers
du couple depuis quatre ans ça devient
l'enfer il a monté sa boîte avec mon
argent et ça traîne
c'est un énorme stress car je n'ai plus
rien je lui ai consacré tout l'argent
que j'avais reçue à la mort de mon père
une femme triste et ruiné un mari obsédé
par sa foi
le couple dupont de ligonnès nom finit
pas de révéler son lot de mystères ils
sont arrivés un peu avant 11h30
les corps d'agnès et de ses quatre
enfants arthur thomas
anne et benoît le dernier de la fratrie
âgé de 13 ans il était enfant de choeur
ici à saint félix c'était un garçon
toujours toujours avec le sourire était
très gentil toujours en train de rigoler
enfin c'était vraiment quelqu'un de bien
pour cette cérémonie l'ensemble du
périmètre a été bouclé les journalistes
à l'écart
la famille a tenu à la plus stricte
intimité mais très vite l'église n'est
pas assez grande pour contenir tout le
monde quelques 1300 personnes parmi
lesquelles de très nombreux jeunes
une partie d'entre eux suivra d'ailleurs
les obsèques dehors grâce à des
hauts-parleurs tandis qu'à l'intérieur
l'un des frères d'agnès de ligonnès
prend la parole à vous tous quelles que
soient les circonstances terribles qui
font que nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui
nous avons envie de dire comme l'a fait
notre saint père le pape benoît 16
il y pas peur un peu plus tard l'abbé
lira quelques mots envoyés par l'évêque
de nantes
l'épreuve est très grande c'est
l'abattement la colère la douleur devant
la mort tragique d'une maman et de ses
quatre enfants
nous sommes devant un abîme d'absurde et
de non sens
la cérémonie dure un peu plus de deux
heures aux dires de tous elle a était
poignante
j'y vais régulièrement dans cette église
et de dimanche à 11h à la messe beaucoup
d'enfants qui crie qui est là c'était
silencieux
personne ne parlait
et avec des pleurs l inhumation d'agnès
de ligonnès et de ses quatre enfants est
prévue samedi matin à 10h30 dans le
département de l'yonne
l'homme le plus recherché de france
s'appelle xavier dupont de ligonnès au
lendemain des obsèques de son épouse et
de ses quatre enfants
un important dispositif de recherche a
été mis en place aujourd'hui à
roquebrune sur argens c'est là bas sur
un parking que l'on avait retrouvé la
semaine dernière son véhicule sur place
olivier théron et virgile ya d'eau
le point de rencontre des enquêteurs
l'hôtel formule 1 de
roquebrune-sur-argens le dernier lieu où
xavier de ligonnès a été formellement
identifié le 15 avril dernier
depuis le principal témoin du quintuple
meurtre de nantes reste introuvable
au coeur du dispositif de recherches la
brigade cynophile aux chiens sont
dressés dans le cadre de la recherche de
restes humains
voilà je peux pas vous en dire plus on
est là pour fermer des portes pour des
recherches dont les bois autour de
l'hôtel 130 crs se déploie pour
quadriller une zone de 25 kilomètres
carrés un hélicoptère équipé d'une
caméra thermique survolait les environs
nous avons des effectifs à terre et eau
en l'air qui vont qui vont surveiller le
terrain qui vont essayer de découvrir
chaque soir c'est justement que vous
avez du pont où l'on se trouve
des plongeurs sont aussi les points
d'eau systématiquement mais en vain
l'opération dure quatre heures le temps
de refermer une porte mais le mystère de
la disparition de xavier de ligonnès
reste lui entier malgré un avis de
recherche international
à la une ce soir également un homme dont
on est toujours sans nouvelles et qui
continue à faire parler de lui me xavier
dupont de ligonnès est toujours à ce
jour introuvable mais c'est une nouvelle
lettre qui intrigue une lettre adressée
à sa mère et à l'une de ses soeurs un
courrier daté du 8 avril qui ressemble à
un testament décryptage frédéric rota
marie cros une énigme de plus xavier
dupont de ligonnès a écrit cette lettre
le 8 avril dernier
quelques jours seulement après la
disparition de sa femme et de ses quatre
enfants elle est adressée à sa mère et à
sa soeur christine qui vivent ensemble
il vient de leur annoncer leur départ
pour les états unis ne vous inquiétez
pas outre mesure tout ira bien et le
temps va passer vite
il joue même les conseils de famille
si vous voulez me faire plaisir en
attendant notre retour profitez-en pour
vous rabibocher avec véro véronique
c'est son autre soeur évoquant ce
différend familial
xavier dupont de ligonnès s'en remet à
ses convictions religieuses dieu
reconnaîtra les siens
la mère a reçu cette lettre le 12 avril
toujours sous le choc elle ne s'exprime
que par l'intermédiaire de son avocat
elle est extrêmement triste elle ne
croit pas du tout en la culpabilité de
son fils malgré l'importance des
éléments et elle m'a dit il faut qu'on
m'apporte la preuve cette lettre at elle
été écrite pour gagner du temps
rassurant la famille plus de quinze
jours après la découverte des corps de
sa femme et de ses quatre enfants xavier
dupont de ligonnès est toujours
introuvable
la dernière preuve de vie de xavier
dupont de ligonnès c'est à ce
distributeur de roquebrune sur argens le
14 avril le lendemain ils séjournent
dans cet hôtel du var où il y abandonne
sa voiture et depuis plus rien suicide
ou cavale organisé pour les enquêteurs
pas de doute c'est lui qui a assassinés
méthodiquement sa femme agnès et ses
quatre enfants
c'était dans la nuit du 4 au 5 avril
leurs corps seront retrouvés quelques
jours plus tard enterrés sous la
terrasse de la maison familiale
cette maison cette terrasse christine
dupont de ligonnès a pu s'y rendre il y
a quelques jours
pour elle aucun doute son frère n'a pas
pu commettre ces meurtres
la hauteur de la terrasse je suis pas
grande
mon frère faisant un mètre 85 me paraît
totalement improbable qu'il ait pu
creuser ces fausses en si peu de temps
tout seul et retirer des mètres cubes de
terre avec un mal de dos habituel
chronique qui n'est un secret pour
personne tous les proches le savent
piquer son absence c'est que je ne peux
pas l'expliquer mais je ne crois pas au
suicide
pourquoi se suiciderait t-il s'il n'est
pas coupable de tout cela et avec le
recul d'une année je ne crois pas à la
fuite puisque je ne le crois pas
coupable
un dossier tentaculaire et des questions
toujours sans réponse
les enquêteurs s'apprêtent d'ailleurs à
tout reprendre à zéro
pour être sûr de n'avoir négliger aucune
piste
[Musique]